strippers or horse oh yeah yeah I didn't
tweet that yeah I did a show on that too
I mean there was another one where it
was um the only fans girls as well that
you basically called them out oh my gosh
I was I was excited because um what's
his face tweeted at me
um Logan Paul's friend Mike yeah I
triggered him I was like I triggered
Mike I'm like it's not my fault you
dated Lana Rhodes seriously like so you
did that anyways um but yeah um I just
thought it would be funny to just tweet
basic things and see if people argued
and then everyone was
me they were like oh
I'm just like okay but she's still
selling her boobs for money and getting
naked like what else do you call that